>> Susannah Raub: Okay, I'd like to, welcome
you to the Maps API & Mobile talk today. I'm
Susannah Raub; I work at Google on the Maps
API team in Sydney. And, we would like you
to, not forget to provide feedback on my presentation
by going to this website, haveasec.com/io,
we'll incorporate your feedback for next year.
Alright, welcome. So, Google Maps API. What
are the options on mobile devices? For lowest
common denominator phones, we offer the Static
Maps API. This requires no JavaScript and,
works on both browser, phones without JavaScript
enables browsers, and also when you're trying
to load just a simple map very quickly, and
don't need the full interactivity of the full
JavaScript API. We also have a number of native
APIs, or one for android, one for iPhone called
map view and map kit. These are developed
in Java and objective C for the iPhone. These
give you a real native experience the way
that the native app does on these phones.
But then we have the JavaScript API. And the
JavaScript API will work on iPhone fully supported,
Android to some extent, and then in the future,
Nokia and Palm. We haven't tested these browsers
yet with our APIs. But, we believe they should
work. So as Vic said at the keynote yesterday,
developing in the browser allows us to write
one application that works on many different
platforms. It would let us solve the cross
device issues instead of worrying about writing
your application, one through the iPhone,
one through Android, one through Nokia, one
through Palms new device announced yesterday.
And who knows what's coming tomorrow, and
where you're gonna have to write your application
one more time. This way, your mashup is also
available not just across different mobile
devices, but on the desktop as well. And,
this goes both ways. If you write a mobile
app, a desktop user can still access your
content. And if you've written a desktop app,
as long as it looks okay on the mobile, a
mobile user can use it too. Of course download
is a great barrier to entry. So, by writing
a, an application in the browser, you require
no download, same usage model that people
are used to for accessing things like Gmail
and other great applications in the browser.
Also, we can release features and bug fixers
much faster in the browser, than a downloaded
application can. You've got to worry about
supporting your old client applications that
are already on phones and the difficulty in
upgrading everybody to your new system. That
goes for both your application being able
to iterate faster, but also the API. That,
there will be in whatever API you're using
at some point, and we can get those fixed
for you right away whereas the application
will rely on you re-downloading with the client
API. But, this comes with a few problems.
So, what makes developing in a mobile browser
tricky? Some of these apply to mobile in general.
But, we've got this issue here that we, we
would like to develop applications that work
both on mobile browsers and on desktop. So
we've got issues around screen size. We need
to think about what you do in this limited
amount of space. And I forgot to introduce,
but I'll comment now. We've got Ken from Lonely
Planet back here. He's going to talk later
and he, he's working on an application for
Lonely Planet that does just this. Is taking
into consideration what you can present to
a user in a small space on this different
model, than we are used to on the desktop.
So we've got to the, we have issues around
screen size. We also have issues around how
the user interacts with the map. That we have
great new technology with being able to touch,
and to pinch, and things like this. But it
also means we need to figure out how to best
write our applications, so we take advantage
of these great features. Then the big one
is speed. Mobile devices are slower. They're
slower from the, the CPU side of things. They're
also on slower networks often with the 3G
or even not 2G networks. So, we need to deal
with issues of reduced bandwidth, but also
reduce performance speed actually running
on the device. Then the last one is the one
that you guys have to tackle. And this is
the use cases. How can we write applications
that make use of the mobile usage? That makes
use of the fact that people are out around
town, not sitting at their computers at home.
So that's where you have to come up with great
new ideas. So let's talk about speed, ‘because
this is really, I would say the biggest thing
with, with the biggest difficulty in developing
on a mobile device, and particularly in a
mobile browser. We have issues in a mobile
browser that don't affect the native app.
One of these is that, iPhone Safari is approximately
10 times slower to Parse JavaScript than desktop
browsers. This is a huge hit. And this isn't
even talking about wireless versus 2G or 3G
network. This is not the time to download.
This is purely what happens when the JavaScript
arrives on your computer or on your mobile
device. Also, caching is limited compared
to desktop browsers. Where you can depend
on your large JavaScript files, your images
been cached in a desktop browser, so it's
a one time upfront hit for the developer or
for the user. On a mobile device, the cache
is small. It would only hold small items.
As you change windows on the iPhone, each
time you go back to a window, it refreshes
the whole page. It has to re download everything.
The cache is not preserved across pages. This
certainly for a monthly API was a big, a big
deal. And then, every millisecond matters.
I think we've said this in a few talks before.
We mentioned this yesterday in the performance
tips for geo APIs. I believe Vic said it in
the keynote yesterday. We found a Google that
every millisecond that it takes to load a
page is fewer users. Users will give up, particularly
on this mobile devices where, who's seen the
iPhone just sitting and spin and spin and
spin and eventually you have to give up, ‘because
you have no confidence it's ever going to
load. So let's talk about what causes these
speed problems, and these causes of latency.
Serving Data: A Google of our servers are
pretty fast where we're pretty confident in
their ability to serve our data quickly. The
time that we're seeing here is negligible
compared to the time it takes. These other
issues, the downloading time, the JavaScript
parsing time, the performance actually on
the device. Now that said, leaving and working
in Australia, I wanna say that if you believe
your users are spread around the world, do
look into, you know, caching solutions and
other places to get your data closer to users.
Distance matters, it takes a long time to
cross the Pacific. It's my little plug for
improve your apps for Australia.
Then download time: So here we need to look
at both bandwidth and latency. Mobile devices
have access to wireless networks, and 3G is
actually fairly high bandwidth. But they're
also high latency. This means that loading,
small and big files, take a surprisingly similar
amount of time. You don't gain a lot by downloading
small files. In fact, you're going to be hurt
by downloading lots and lots of small files.
As opposed to, perhaps one medium or big files.
Then there is the JavaScript parsing time.
And as I've already mentioned, this is about,
we've seen it to be about ten times slower
on the iPhone than on a desktop browser. This
is CPU Bound, and we're expected to improve
over time, which is the good news. That is
the hardware improves, we're seeing improvement,
also as the software improves. The JavaScript
parsing libraries are getting better as well.
So this may not be a problem forever, but
it's certainly a problem now. I want to back
up a moment, and I'm using this term latency,
but what is it? And I want you to think about
it in 2 ways. One is that it's the page load
time. It's the time it takes until absolutely
everything on your page is visible, loaded,
visible and usable. But then, maybe more importantly,
arguable, maybe not, is user perceived latency,
and this is the time until the page appears
to have loaded. So, this is the time when
a user says okay, my page is here and I can
start doing something with it. And even if
things are still loading in the back ground,
on non-visible parts of the page, or things
that you're not gonna have to interact with
right away. This really improves the user
experience. This is one of the, we've measured
both of these, and this is another point I
want to make, measure these things. Measure
how long your, pages is taking to load, and
how long, define what it is until the user
is able to use your page, and measure that
as well. And work to reduce both of them.
So how can we reduce latency on mobiles?
We can reduce the size of JavaScript, and
recommend compiling or obfuscating your code.
Compiling it can help you catch errors, but
more importantly, by obfuscating that you
can take all of your long variable names that
make your code nice and readable. It takes
your variable names, your function names,
your class names; it makes them into short
1, 2, 3 character variables functions and
class names. You may have noticed that the
Google Maps API is obfuscated, this may make
it a pain sometimes to, to debug, but it's
not just there so you can't read our source
code. It is also there so that we can load
this API as quickly as possible for you. We,
you can reduce the size probably; I guess
it's about, 10 times, 100 times. It's remarkably
slower. And the compilers out there, obfuscators,
they do lots of optimizations around strings,
and, and other, all kinds of optimizations
to help reduce this even further, It's not
just simple renaming. The other thing is to
combine your image fetchers by using spreads.
You may have heard this one before. Each download
on the iPhone takes, has significant overhead.
And there're limited numbers of open connections
on the iPhone, like any browser. And so, by
combining your images that are all going to
be used at the same time, into one and then
spreading them, putting them in separate disc,
will help you out a lot. So what happens when
you either don't have JavaScript, available
on the phone, or you really need something
super super fast? We have the Static Maps
API for you. This, we have some people who
are using this where it loads the Static Map
and then converts it to a dynamic map after
the rest of the page is loaded. This is a
great way to reduce user perceived latency,
or, sometimes on a page you may want a map
showing, you don't need to load that whole
map unless you really think the user is going
to interact with it. And so you can delay
low the actual JavaScript at that point as
well. So, we see that there are a number of
parameters that you pass it; fairly simply,
there is a center, a zoom, a size. The map
tapes available are, train, road map, satellite
and hybrid. And then you can even put markers
on, and polylines it requires an API key,
and then you need to specify whether or not
you're using this on a GPS enabled application
by specifying the sensor parameter. That's
all there's to it. Let's say you need to Geocode
with it. Well, instead of downloading the
whole API in order to, in order to do your
Geocoding with the G-Client GEO-CODER, you
can use http Geocoding service. Reverse Geocoding
is also available. Unlike the static maps
API, it's just passing a few parameters. So
you give it the query, your output, which
could be JSON, KML, CSV, and X-Mail, and your
encoding also requires an API key and the
sensor parameter. So now, you can build a
full map with Geocoding without having to
download a bit of our JavaScript.
Well, let's go back to the JavaScript API.
How well does V2 work on mobile browsers?
Ken, how well does this work?
>> Ken: Not very.
>> Susannah Raub: Not very, he says. So, the
initial download back when it was released
in 2006 was 60 kilobytes. It's now about 190
kilobytes, that's ‘because we brought
you so many great features. The time to load
tiles also really affects how our API does,
but because we are loading these tiles we
give them some patting. It can take a long
time to get these tiles to you. We have synchronous
access to a lot of state, and this has limited
our ability to delay-load code. So because
we give you for every single feature we release,
all these different gathers after you've manipulated
the map in some way, means that we have to
actually upfront. Synchronously, we have to
have computed all those values. This code
base was not designed with mobile in mind.
It is a great API, and it works very nicely
on desktops, but it wasn't, it didn't need
to fit the needs of these browsers back when
it was written a few years ago. So, here I'm
gonna introduce to you today, a new version
of the API (God, I like this), [laughter].
So, [clapping] we released this API yesterday,
and it's right now a limited feature set of
the V2 API, but we wanted to get it out to
you. Let you start writing your simple applications
on it, and using our, I'll talk of more of
our architecture, but using our behind the
scenes architecture to write some really rich
applications on it. We wanted you to get this,
do this fast right away so that we can start
adding the features, the more complex features
later. So how does V3 address the issues that
I've brought up previously?First, the initial
download size is significantly reduced. It's
35kilobytes. So we're just about half of what
the, the first API was three years ago. This
significantly reduces the loading time, and
I will show you this in a moment. We incorporate
the static map for you by loading that first
before tiles load. We even make it draggable,
and this is to reduce the user perceived latency.
So you shouldn't even notice that we've loaded
the static mapping first. We're designing
with mobile devices in mind, so we've tried
to get it to feel like those native APIs,
what's available if you run it natively instead
of in the browser. And, we're seeing that
as hardware improves. So as hardware improves
also on OS3, we're seeing that this is really
starting to feel good.So let me show you,
V2 versus V3. I'm gonna load them both. Now,
the network as you may have noticed is sometimes
little hard to connect to. So last night whiles
everybody was partying this worked beautifully.
We'll hope its still, [pauses] [laughs]. So
you can see they look the same, right? Wait,
I'm on the wrong thing. Now, you can see they
look the same. It's good. So I'm gonna go
here. I'm gonna click on a little. So we got
here, I'm gonna press GO at the same time,
and, the one on the left is V2. The one on
the right is V3. To emphasize this, the V2
one is running on our brand new shiny iPod
Touch running on OS3 and our V3 one is running
on the slightly older iPhone with OS2. Alright,
we're having some network connection problems
on the I Phone. [Laughter]. Okay, we'll try
again. [Laughter]. So, OS3 is the one running
V2, which shows us V2 over in the southern
ocean. Okay, I'll try again and then we'll,
[pauses]. Well, the cache had cleared itself
[Laughter]. Okay, it worked so beautifully
last night. It's too bad on OS3. I can't get
my finger to drive over. Okay. There we go.
Yeah, that's right. It's the network. Now,
neither of them wants to connect. Alright,
no, they're both on WI-FI. It says that HTTP
Data Roaming is off. It's actually we don't
have 3G access because they are for Australia.
Okay. So okay my race isn't working today,
but you can believe me that it is faster [laughter].
So here we go, here are some numbers for you.
We found in general, what's that? Oh, I need
to switch. Thanks. So in general, we found
that it takes about nine seconds in V2 to
download that first JavaScript download which
we call Main.js. It takes about two seconds
to download that, on, over, this is over,
we believe over 3G for both numbers. But,
so about two seconds on V3. Now, V3 numbers
are purely in our test lab. We don't, it's
not been used by enough people to have really
good numbers the way we might have for what's
out there Live. But, this is a pretty good
estimate of how long things take. And then,
the time to load tiles which I'm actually
defining as, the time to load a map that can
be dragged, is about 18 seconds on V2 and
about 7 seconds on V3, and we see great improvements
on that on Wireless over 3G for that tile
downloading. So you can see it wasn't, oh
wait. You weren't watching. I was watching.
This one was really still very slow, because
I think it's the iPhone versus the, It's just
not connecting well. So it wasn't V2 and V3
[laughs]. So how did we accomplish this improvement?
As I mentioned, we're using the static map
under the hood to render the map faster, and
this will happen whenever you change zoom
levels and when you load a map. So we should
be getting you the fastest map possible when
there is a big map change. Now, the other
improvements were made mostly because we use
this MVC Architecture, MVC being Model View
Controller. So what we do is we load our state
storing models initially. This way, you can
have, you have access or everything you access
is a model, and you have access to set and
get the properties of that model, and when
you create something like a map, we then,
asynchronously download the code necessary
to render that which is completely separate
from the actual model that's storing the state
where your zoom and your center and your map
type are. So, when we download the views to,
for the map and marker, we get all of the
complicated DIVs and CSS and Interaction and
event handling, but when that's downloaded
and the user can begin interacting with the
map. They, the events that are, that happen
there affect the model. So, for example, when
the user double clicks we change both the
zoom property and the center property. These
properties then are changed back on the model
because we've used these binding where they
really share the value. The model can decide
at that point whether it wants to take that
value or whether it needs to edit it. For
example on zoom, the models says, wait a second,
the zoom level you've given me is invalid.
Because we've gone one level too far or one
level, one level too far in either direction.
And the model says, nope. I'm not gonna accept
that change. It doesn't update that state.
So nothing gets notified of a change, but
if it does update that state then everything
that's bound to that property throughout the
entire system updates that change. So I'm
gonna show you an example of how to use this.
But before that, I'll explain. You can do
something where you have a DIV that's displaying
the zoom level, and if you bind that product
to the zoom change property, you will at anytime
be able to just get the zoom level from it.
I'll show you more lately. Because we are
only loading a small state storing model for
each feature that we have, we expect that
our size increase for new features will be
minimal. You hopefully will not notice any
impact of new features on the size of the
download. This has also helped us to untangle
code, and should help us to add new features
and fix bugs faster.
So what does V3 look like?
It's somewhat similar to V2. It's a totally
new interface, so you will have to rewrite
your applications from scratch. There's absolutely
no backwards compatibility. Though, we have
tried to maintain the same features. Well,
feature is not quite because we're started
with a small set. They'll plan to add features,
but if a, value return, if a method returns
some value in V2, we're trying to return that
same value so that it's a poet, not a full
rewrite. So you can see that you create a
map, which is all stored in a Google. Maps
name space, and pass it to DIV just like before.
And then, you can pass, right now; it's an
options object here, the center, the zoom,
and the map type ID. Not a map type object,
but a map type ID. You pass these in, and
this will create a map right away. If you
want a wait, and set the center and zoom and
map type ID later, and I'll show you an example
why you might want to do that. We also have
methods that you can call, call set center,
set zoom, set map type ID. Then, we can create
a marker to go on this map, and we give it
a position, and we give it a map. And this
will right away render it on a map. You can,
here also we have functions, methods available
for you to set these properties individually.
So if you wanted to move your marker at some
point, you can just say marker.set_position
and give it a new LatLing. So, let me find
a demo here. I'm gonna find it, and then I'll
show it to you. Oh wait, this one's aren't
here. So here is a demo using this MVC Architecture,
using on V3. So we have a big map and you'll
notice on the right hand corner that there's
this little overlay map. Now in V2, there
is an overlay map option, and this takes probably
hundreds lines of code in, our, in that Main.js
file that you're downloading. Hundreds of
lines of codes are needed in order for you
to be able to display this overlay map. But
I'll show you how you can implement one of
these yourself using MVC and V3. Here is the
code. Can you see that okay? I did my own
syntax highlighting, so I hope you can see
it well. So what we're gonna do is, we're
gonna initialize two maps. One is full size,
and that's defined by the DIVs that you've
created down below in the page. And one is
a small DIV in the corner of the large map,
calling this map an Overlay Map. So I've initialized
a map, but I have not given it any properties
to begin with. Then in the Overlay Map, I'm
gonna specify that it's got a road map type.
It's not gonna change. It's always gonna be
a road map and I'm gonna disable the default
UI. Disabling the default UI means that we
won't show you the zoom control, the map type
control, or any other controls that we decide
to put on it someday in the future. Then,
I'm gonna setup these two event listeners.
Where I'm listening to the zoom change events
because what I want is the Overlay Map to
show the same exact map as the big one, but
four zoom levels out. So the map, oh, and
I want the map. If you click on the, if you
zoom in on the Overlay Map I want the map
to reflect that change as well. So I'm gonna
have the map listen to the event, or I'm gonna
listen to these zoom changed event on the
map. And when it changes, I will calculate
the new zoom level which is four zoom levels
higher than the, or zoomed out than the map,
and set that to be the zoom level of the Overlay
Map. I'm going to check that it hasn't changed
to avoid some infinite recursion here. Because,
then, I'm also going to listen to the zoom
changed event on the Overlay Map which will
be triggered anytime the zoom level changes
there, either through set zoom or the user
double clicking on the map. And when the Overlay
Map zoom level changes, I'm going to reset
the zoom level of the map. Then, because I
want their centers to stay in line, I bind,
I use this method called Bind To, and I bind
the Overlay Map center to the map center.
This means every time the map center changes,
the overlay map is notified of a center change,
but also, it center just is the same. Every
time, if you called Overlay Map.getcenter.
You will get the actual same object that Map.getcenter
would return. So not just the same value,
but the same exact object. Then, I'm gonna
set the properties on the map. I didn't, the
zoom is the important one here. I didn't set
the zoom initially because if I set the zoom
initially, then the Overlay Map would not
have been notified yet of the zoom changed
event. The zoom changed event happens as soon
as set zoom is called. So now I set the zoom,
and just because I was setting the zoom down
here, I decided to set the center and the
map type ID. Unlike these event listeners,
Bind to will notify of the initial setting
of this property when you call Bind To. So
in the case, if I set the center above, then,
I could have set Overlay Map Bind to Map Center,
and it would have gotten center changed event.
Now, this may sound fairly complicated. You
don't actually need to use this to write a
simple map application. We can hide most of
this from you, but I wanted to show you rich
it can be, and emphasize that these, that
each of these MVC properties, zoom, center,
map type ID. These are the bindable properties.
These are represented with the set underscore
and get underscore notation. This is because
it's how it's implemented on the back end,
but it makes it clear which are MBC properties
and which ones are not. There's also, you'll
notice on this [pauses]. Where is my demo?
On the demo, there is this blue rectangle
in the corner. I've highlighted the code for
it, but this is, the blue rectangle is being
shown because the map has a bounds property
and it is binding to the bounds changed events
where I think I should implement a method
called Bounds Changed, which is another way
of doing this and we'll have more documentation
on it. But it pays attention to the bounds,
and it renders its blue rectangle as the bounds
with the map change. And I will give you time
to ask some questions, but something else
that we're making sure that we do in this
case, in V3 is to adjust for screen size.
So, though V2 did some of this as well, we're
really taking it seriously in V3 making sure
that your info windows don't appear larger
than your map, making sure that your controls
are the right size. Not even on the iPhone,
we won't even show you the zoom control by
default because you can pinch.
What else is new in V3?
Chrome is supported, iPhone Safari is supported,
Android works pretty well, but we've still
got some bugs that we're working out. So though
you can use it, we're not officially supporting
it. Big news is no keys are required. You
can now run your application on any domain.
You don't have to register for different keys,
none of this. So, [pauses], you're welcome
[clapping]. We also, the default UI is also
enabled by default. So this means that if
we introduce new UI elements to Maps.google.com,
you will see them on your API site unless
you disable the default UI. So you can disable
the default UI and you can control all of
the controls yourself, but you don't need
to. If you just want to follow along and get
our updates as we add new things to it. Included
in this is keyboard handling when we influence
scroll wheel zooms, scroll wheel zoom is part
of default UI. Another big thing that we do
is, we adjust your controls for the size of
your map. So if you want a large zoom control
on a big map and a small one on a small map,
and none on the iPhone, and the Android style
on the Android, we'll take care of that for
you. Just leave default UI enabled. We also
have a new Geocoding API. So we took into
consideration all the things that you've been
telling us for the last few years and have
a new API. The old one is not available on
V3, but we think you'll like the new one better.
And as I have mentioned, we have unlimited
features now. We have a map marker, info-window,
custom overlays which can be implemented using
something called the Overlay View, Geocoding,
probably some more that I'm forgetting. But,
these are your features today. And, I'm going
to demo, hopefully. One of our trusted testers
is Tapster, and they have an application that
is running that shows you live traffic based
on GPS devices. And so, here it is in the
iPhone, and I loaded it before. So hopefully
it will still be working, but you can see
you can click on any of these little markers,
and it shows you the speed and the date and
time of what's happening there. They've implemented
their own zoom control here. And, you can
see that though tiles have taken a while to
load on here, but it's working pretty well.
Oh, the port network. Okay. Well, we're not
loading tiles right now. Okay, let's, I'm
gonna go back to V3 and show you some of our,
my demo page and show you some of our panning
and zooming. Hopefully, it will finish loading.
If you're using your phone right now, you
know, maybe you could stop [Laughter]. I encourage
you to try this outside of this building.
You may have witnessed already that our connection
is difficult on the mobile devices. Okay,
well, it's not loading right now. So, I think
I'm gonna hand it over to Ken. Well, here
we go. So here's, so he asks about the version
3 tiles server. We're using all the same tiles.
We're using all the same images, everything,
all that backend infrastructure is the same.
So you can see that I zoomed in there using
pinch to zoom, and once the tiles are loaded
in there it works pretty nicely. Alright,
so now, to hear from a developer using the
map's API. I hand it over to Ken, and I'll
be back up for questions.
>> Ken Hoetmer: Okay, thank you Susannah.
So, I should switch. I'm Ken, I'm from Lonely
Planet. If you haven't used Lonely Planet,
I'll just give a brief introduction. We are
a guide book company primarily. If you go
to a book store, you go to the travel section.
You'll find all sorts of guide books there
that we produce, country guides, like this
one is in Nepal, city guides, New Orleans.
We have new series called California, well,
called US Trips. California Trips is one of
them, guide books for how to travel very cheaply.
It's, some people don't realize that you can
travel on $10 a day if you go to the right
place. Activity guides, language guides, if
you need to learn Burmese to speak to a monk
when you get there, and sort of pictorial
coffee table type books. This last one is
my favorite. It's the Lonely Planet Guide
to the Middle of Nowhere. We also have a digital
site of our business. We have a website –
Lonelyplanet.com. A mobile site for the iPhone
Touch – Touch.lonelyplanet.com, which
is what I will be talking about really here.
Mobile sites for other devices – m.lonleyplanet.com,
native guide book APPs for the iPhone, Native
Phrasebook Apps for iPhone, Android, and Blackberry,
and then a couple new applications that are
coming soon for Android. So, thinking about
maps on mobile devices from a traveler perspective.
This is really rough. I've said three main
features and obviously we can debate this,
we can have a whole session on what we really
want maps to do on mobile device. But these
are the three really basic things, like where
is it, meaning there is a pizza place, or
there is the bay bridge, or there is whatever
it is that I'm interested in. I wanna know
where it is, what's around it that might be
interesting to see while I'm there, and to
get me there to navigate me to that place.
Now, that could be simply by looking at the
map and following it by looking at street
signs, or perhaps there's GPS integration
or driving directions or something like that.
And if we can locate the device, then you
can start asking couple more interesting things
like, where am I right now and what's around
me right now at this moment. So how do we
deal with that in all of our mobile products?
For iPhone City Guide App, we have a tile
server. We actually cache tiles on the devices
and we use route-me library. Not some set
of all five requirements that I just sketched
for mobile, but it's not cross-platform obviously
its native App in the iPhone. For m.lonleyplanet.com,
we use a static maps API. Susannah mentioned
later, so we can display points of interest
and things around them by generating a static
map with markers on it. And then, we have
simulated map navigation by using Mercator
Projection Class in the backend which can
decide what the URL of a static map that would
seem to have been the place you will go by
navigating north, south, east or west. Does
that make sense? So we have links that go
up, down, left, right that will move the map
that will actually take you to a new page
that has another static map that has just
shifted. And that's sort of adequate for where
is it, what's around it when I see point of
interest on our mobile site, but you know,
to get me there, part of it to where I am,
what's around me, obviously is not very well
supported. And, on our iPhone site, what we
did is, we created a KML link to the iPhone's
native maps App, because what we had available
to us in the browser just wasn't sufficient.
And it was actually a debate internally about
how we can do that. Should we use static maps
API on the iPhone site, or should we link
to the native App? And we decided we should
just link to Native App even though that meant
people will be leaving our site and maybe
never coming back. Well, hopefully they come
back, but not coming back potentially because
whether in the Native App they start doing
searches there. They do directions look ups,
they use the GPS, and the iPhone users really
are expecting that of rich functionality on
the iPhone. And it's pretty hard to give a
static map on our website. I don't know, iPhone
don't expect people to be satisfied with that.
So, the alternative, when Google sort of approached
us and said they're building this new JavaScript
Maps API that was targeted on mobile was perfect
for us in the context of our browser based
iPhone website – Touch.lonelyplanet.com.
This is great for the, where it was, and what's
around it, kind of thing. If you're looking
at point of interest in OS 3.0, the Geo Location
API will be supported, so we can start to
get the users' location into the browser.
It keeps user on our site instead of having
to go to the map's application on the iPhone,
and we can still open the Natives Map Apps
for directions or just give the user that
option should they desire. So just do a demo
and this live? If you go to Touch.lonelyplanet.com
on your iPhone, and I will also not tell you
that if you go there on the Android phone
that you were given, it will not work, and
that's because we don't support it, if that
makes sense [laughs]. It works on Android,
but we don't support it and there are a few
bugs that the Google APIs still has, but you
can go try Touch.lonleyplanet.com on your
Android phone, and see an implementation of
the new maps API. Oh, I should switch this.
Okay. So that's front page of Touch.lonelyplanet.com.
I'm going to find the destinations, and it
remembers one of my previous locations so
I'm not gonna bother typing. I'll just pick
San Francisco. Come on, network. Great! So
there's all sort of things about San Francisco.
Things, weather, health and safety, that sort
of thing, and I go to things to see and do,
press it again. Should have taken dance lessons
from Lars this morning [laughs]. You got up
on yours? [Laughter] Why not? This is what
you'll get [laughter] [clapping]. Mine is
still not there. Sights, I'm gonna see what's
around See. I'm there on this phone now, so
might have to just [laughter], fantastic.
So there are also some places that I can see
around San Francisco. I'm going to pick, oh
I don't know, Bob Kaufman Alley. Check that
out. Is there anyone else having another iPhone
that's managed to get ahead of me [laughter]?
Yep. Oh, it's up, it's up. Okay. Well, here's
the other part that I was hoping to get to
quickly and then spend a little bit time on
and as if I could show that. Cross your fingers.
Well, previously, this will link out to the
iPhone's Native App once this loads [laughter].
I should mention that we're based in Australia,
so that's why we don't have 3G on our phones
either. We got Australian phones. You'd get
something like this [clapping], and as you
can see, we've created our own, well, not
our own, we've copied an info window from
another place you may have seen before. That's
the custom info window that says crossroads
there, that is implemented using the overlay
view class in the Maps API version 3. We've
used custom icons that we had. What we've
done is, we've made an AJAX call to our content
servers to load in all of the, in this case,
it's the shocks in San Francisco onto the
map. And then, few other features of what
we've done. If you scroll the map, we're listening
to the bounds changed event, and it will populate
other things that are outside of the map bounds.
And that helps keep it zippy on the iPhone
browser which isn't a very high powered browser
for JavaScript. So, then, I can just click
on one of these. I can click on the info window
and go to that, go to that point of interest;
I can ask what's nearby that one. To get a
list, I can show that list on a map. There
we go. I can switch between places to shop
and places to see, and you get the idea. We
haven't all of the pinch events and the swipes
and all of those things are included by defaults
in version three. We haven't done anything
differently on the interface side of things
and actually if you go to this page and start
using our site on your Android phone, you'll
see that there are actually zoom buttons that
will appear on your page because the API recognizes
that you are on Android and not on iPhone.
And if you go to Touch.lonelyplanet.com on
your desktop browser and load it up, obviously
the experience isn't designed for that, but
you will see the default UI for the desktop
browser show up. And, I think that's all from
me. We'll move into questions now. You can
ask Susannah whatever questions you want,
or ask me anything about implementing this
that we run into.
>> Susannah Raub: – Can you come up
to the mic? Maybe that will happen. Do come
up to the mic, so that helps everybody hear
your questions. So we encourage you to do
that [Clapping]. Alright, here we go.
>> Are you planning, hello, can you hear me,
yeah? Are you planning to do a, sort of the
map view also, eventually? I mean, it's nice
that you guys kind of recreated that, the
view. So I'm just wondering if that's something
that…
>> Susannah Raub: Do the map view, what…
>> Sorry, so that, I mean, it looks like the
native iPhone sort of maps control.
>> Ken Hoetmer: Oh, that's a question for
me. That's a custom info window that we created,
which are source isn't obfuscated you can
just go look at it and check out and, you
know, and go use it yourself. We did that
to give the feeling that people have, when
they're on the Native App. So it gives a feeling
of the iPhone experience, yeah.
>> okay.
>> So, when you show me a bunch of restaurants,
that doesn't mean much to me. I'm not interested
in just going to any restaurant that happens
to be nearby, right? So, are you gonna add
more depths to what you find, in terms of
maybe personal preferences I might have stored
in my contact information? Or something that
gives me a little more intelligent, search
for things that you show up on Lonely Planet?
>> Ken Hoetmer: You're asking a tough Lonely
Planet product question. How about we talk
about that offline [laughter]? That's all
I can say, that's all I can say.
>> Susannah Raub: Yes.
>> Hey, I know this discussion has been in
the context of mobile, but I'm wondering if
any of these V3, any of the V3 API will be
available from within the Google map's flash
API? Is that another…?
>> Susannah Raub: So, this is purely JavaScript
now that the flash API is completely separate.
Are you asking if like the, the MVC stuff
would be available in flash or…?
>> Well, more just kind of the optimizations
that you've made in terms of the static image
loading and things like that.
>> Susannah Raub: I can't, maybe …..
We have found that on desktop. Loading the
static map first doesn't make such a big difference.
It definitely makes a difference, but it's
not as critical as it is on the slower mobile
devices.
>> Are you sure?
>> Susannah Raub: Yes.
>> Cool.
>> Susannah Raub: Thanks.
>> So, in version two, there was a quick-mode
so you can get it to work with other device
types like Net Front Browsers, and you know,
alternative browsers. In version three, you're
focused on mobile, right? So, is it centered
around web kit? So, if I'm using like, a Net
Front, you know which is an access browser
or Limo which is an open source browser. Is
it going to render that way as well?
>> Susannah Raub: So it should be the same
across browsers for now. We are, we do test
on web kit browsers, but we haven't done anything
special for web kit browsers versus other
browsers. Not yet.
>> Okay.
>> Susannah Raub: Before everybody leaves,
I would like to come in to, we have a fire
side chat for Geo at 12:00, in the fire side
chat room. So if you have question that go
beyond just this API, come join us there,
and you should also give feedback on this
presentation at haveasec.com/io. Now, move
on with questions, yes.
>> Can I ask questions on static map? ‘Cause
I used static map for the first load, would
be nice to support polygons if you're requesting
it for you're…
>> Susannah Raub: It would be nice to support
polygons. Yes, you're right.
>> We'll be supporting it [fades]
>> Susannah Raub: We'll work on it. We know
it would be nice.
>> … instead of users, look at white
space if you load that first.
>> Alright. Are you gonna roll the App Cache
stuff into the V3 API?
>> Susannah Raub: So that's the APP Cache
that's the H – Channel 5, the database
stuff or…?
>> Yeah.
>> Susannah Raub: Yeah. So, we, we've looked
into some of the stuff. I believe it's difficult
to do cross domain and so I think it's something
you can put on your site and take advantage
of, but we may not be able to build in ourselves.
>> Okay. Thanks.
>> I just have a question about the draggable
pin. Is that possible also in the browser
with this new version?
>> Susannah Raub: The draggable…
>> Pin that you can do in the native maps
application on the iPhone.
>> Susannah Raub: That you can drag the marker?
>> Yeah.
>> Susannah Raub: Not currently, but like
these are some of the features that we have
in V2 that we would like to have and once
we support draggable markers, they will work
in the iPhone as well, but right now they
are just clickable. Any more questions? Thanks
for joining us, and good luck in writing your
V3 applications [clapping].